ja die größte batterie der welt sie ist
wirklich unfasslich gigantisch im
letzten video haben wir noch über die
größte batterie farben der welt von
ihnen masken südaustralien berichten
heute geht es also noch größer
die größte batterie der welt wie diese
mega batterie genau funktioniert und ob
sie die dringend notwendige energiewende
leichter zur realität werden lässt jetzt
den klicks von science fiction herzlich
willkommen erneuerbare energien sind die
zukunft doch sie haben bislang einen
entscheidenden nachteil überschritt sich
produzierter strom kann nicht wirklich
zwischengespeichert werden für zeiten in
denen es beispielsweise weniger sonne
oder wind gibt jetzt gibt es
fortschritte bei einem wirklich
vielversprechenden lösungsansatz der
weltweit größten batterie die mit hilfe
von salzkavernen betrieb werden soll
wenn man dem oldenburger
energieversorger ewe glauben geht es
jetzt um den zaubertrank der
energiewende und ja ich muss zugeben
wenn der plan aufgehen sollte wäre das
wirklich fast zu schön um wahr zu sein
es besteht die möglichkeit etwas
wirklich revolutionäres zu schaffen sagt
einer der beteiligten ulrich schubert
vom centre for energy and environment
chemistry in jena
denn es könnte tatsächlich das
kernproblem der energiewende lösen wir
haben hier ja schon öfter darüber
berichtet strom aus erneuerbaren quellen
lässt sich mittlerweile preis künstlich
herstellen wenn die sonne scheint oder
es wind gibt doch wie dann speichern für
schlechte zeiten es scheint wie verhext
weder bei den angedachten pumpspeichern
am meeresgrund noch bei
pumpspeicherkraftwerken tut sich etwas
genauso wenig wie bei anderen möglichen
speichertechniken alle haben nur eines
gemeinsam von einem großtechnischen
einsatz sind sie noch weit entfernt um
so mehr hoffnungen also wird jetzt in
das projekt von ewe und der universität
jena gesetzt kurz zusammengefasst die
weltgrößte batterie bei der energie in
flüssigkeit gespeichert wird und zwar in
sole also in salzwasser wenn der
speicher sollen in zwei unterirdischen
salzkavernen seinen platz finden
das projekt heißt one for power und die
anlage soll eine kapazität von 700
megawattstunden haben also in etwa die
menge strom die etwa 75.000 haushalte an
einem tag verbraucht
in planung ist diese sogenannte polymer
redox flow batterie schon länger doch
jetzt aktuell wurde ein weiteres
zwischen ergebnis verkündet wie der name
der mega batterie schon verrät sollen
organische polymere eine zentrale rolle
spielen diese organischen kunststoffe
können elektronen aufnehmen und abgeben
und das besondere sie sind sogar in
gesättigtem salzwasser stabil so die
neue erkenntnis des forschungsteams aus
jena zitat wir können diese polymere so
modifizieren dass sie in der sohle
gelöst drinbleiben und nicht aus falls
damit haben wir gezeigt dass man
kavernen für die batterie nutzen kann
sagt ulrich schubert die unterirdischen
salzkavernen von denen ewe über 38 stück
verfügt enthalten genau solche
salzlösung auf englisch brian auf
chemischer ebene läuft das dann so in
zwei salzstöcken werden jeweils tausende
tonnen solcher polymer moleküle in lauge
gelöst in der elektrochemischen zelle
findet dann die reaktion statt die
beiden speicher flüssigkeiten namens
katholisch und analyse sind getrennt
durch eine membran und können sich nicht
vermischen doch die membran ist ionen
durchlässig diese können von der einen
elektrolytlösung in die andere gelangen
durch die stromzufuhr von außen
beispielsweise durch einen windpark gibt
der katholik seiner elektronen ab er
oxidiert an den polymeren des anno lutz
dagegen werden elektronen angelagert das
nennt man dann reduktion der eine
salzstock funktioniert also als pluspol
der andere als minuspol und die
aufgeladene moleküle werden dann in
speicher behälter gepumpt andere
ungeladene moleküle werden hinzugegeben
umgekehrt läuft die entladung der
batterie ab dann geben die analyt
moleküle ihre elektronen ab die stehen
dann als elektrischer strom zur
verfügung es ist tatsächlich wahnsinn
der einzige faktor der die maximale
speicherkapazität dieser batterie
einschränkt ist die größe der speicher
behälter für die elektrolyt
flüssigkeiten
ein weiterer vorteil es gibt keine
selbstentladung die technik an sich ist
eigentlich nicht neu im prinzip wird
schon seit jahrzehnten getüftelt doch
bislang brauchte man schwermetalle wie
vanadium und die sind teuer
das kann jetzt durch die organische
polymere ersetzt werden
und jetzt noch ein paar zahlen und
fakten für euch die kosten der redox
flow batterie sein
mit denen von pumpspeicherkraftwerken
sagen die verantwortlichen von ewe 70
betrage der wirkungsgrad und rund 20
tausend ladezyklen das ist eine menge
sein ohne starke effizienz verluste
möglich bisher hat sich ewe allerdings
noch nicht auf einen standort festgelegt
dass sollen bis ende 2019 passieren in
frage kommt zum beispiel im gum in
ostfriesland etwa 50 kilometer entfernt
liegt der offshore-windpark riffgat von
ewe abgesehen von wissenschaftlichen und
technischen risiken die bleiben muss man
also die ersten fahrversuche abwarten
bis dahin wird noch einiges an
forschungs stattfinden müssen und
vorstellbar wäre auch der einsatz der
redox flow batterie in elektroautos es
ist schon absolut irre was ich in den
letzten jahren in der batterietechnik so
getan hat wenn er kein video zu diesem
thema gleich kommen noch 1 verpassen
wollt dann drückt mir hier ein abo aufs
auge und vergesst nicht den auf die
glocken und dann werdet ihr auch über
neue videos informierte geht es weiter
mit dafür draufklicken revolution super
akkus erfunden dass es auch wirklich
eine absolut sensationelle technik also
bis dann bleibt dran